hello welcome to breakthroughs from
science mission I'm sadashiva pi and
going to discuss couple of breakthrough
papers published in the week of june
nine let's start first we will discuss a
paper published by Randall chin in
nature on the mechanism of alpha
ketoglutarate mediated lifespan
extension why is this paper so important
mechanism of aging is not clearly
understood author sure that alpha
ketoglutarate extends longevity in C
elegans and elicited molecular mechanism
of lifespan extension by alpha
ketoglutarate author screen normal
metabolites and aberrant
disease-associated metabolites and
discovered that the TCA cycle
intermediate alpha ketoglutarate but not
isocitrate or citrate delays aging and
extends lifespan of C elegans by 50%
alpha-ketoglutarate responses those
dependent as shown here the deletion or
killing of C elegans bacterial food
source has been shown to extend worm
lifespan but the lifespan increased by
alpha ketoglutarate is not due to
altered bacterial proliferation or
metabolism as shown here increasing
alpha ketoglutarate levels by RNA
interference that inhibits alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase also extends
worm lifespan consistent with a direct
effect of alpha ketoglutarate on
longevity independent of bacterial food
how does alpha ketoglutarate increase
lifespan authors used biochemical
approach darts in jurkat cells and found
that alpha ketoglutarate bind
specifically to ATP 5 b subunit of ATP
synthase they also show alpha
ketoglutarate inhibition of activity of
complex 5 in heart mitochondria and
decreased ATP levels and oxygen
consumption in the matters of after
alpha keita butyrate treatment so alpha
ketoglutarate binds and inhibits ATP
synthase
since starvation also increases lifespan
authors looked at starvation in
nematodes and found that alpha
ketoglutarate levels are elevated in
star C elegans since mtor pathway
annoyed in starvation authors
investigated this pathway and found that
tour pathway activity is decreased in
human cells treated with octal alpha
ketoglutarate also alpha theta greater
did not cause significantly more
autophagy in either a tp2 RNAi or let
363 are in the eye worms indicating that
alpha ketoglutarate pathway feeds into
tour pathway so here is the pathway
authors propose for the mechanism of
alpha ketoglutarate mediated increase in
lifespan next let's look into the paper
published by Scott and colleagues in
cell authors provide mechanism of action
of click 16a why is this paper so
important click 16a has been implicated
in type 1 diabetes multiple clip
sclerosis and adrenal dysfunction but
its function is not known author show
that collects 16 interaction with
proteins in mitophagy pathway they also
demonstrate regulation of pancreatic
function by clec 16a let's look at the
experimental data authors demonstrate
interaction between clicks 16a with e3
ubiquitin ligase an RDP one authors also
showed that proteasome inhibitor mg132
treatment to collect 16 a knockout
fibroblast normalized expression in
reduction of nadp one suggesting that
collect 16-year protects an RDP one from
proteasomal degradation an RDP one
regulates producer multi gradation of e3
ligase parking during mitophagy Parkin
moves to mitochondria clec 16 a knockout
increases parking levels as shown here
and we are not reduced following fccp
mediate might of AG in knocker
fibroblast parking was found in
mitochondrial fraction parking ubiquiti
needs might refuse in one and two and
promote their degradation my diffusion
to expression was reduced in knocker
fibroblast consistent with increased
Park in activities in mitochondria
collect 16 a loss reduced oxygen
consumption rate in fibroblasts and
could be rescued by an RDP one
transfection similar result is also seen
in her in a high knockout so clec 16e
restraints mitophagy by a ni DP 1
parking pathway others generated
pancreatic specific like 16 a knockout
mice and they were significantly
hyperglycemic compared to littermate
controls in intraperitoneal glucose
tolerance testing also these mice showed
reduced basil and blunted insulin
release indicating impaired glucose
tolerance in vivo loss of 16 a in beta
cells displayed an accumulation of
regulated structures partially degraded
cytoplasmic material consistent with
autophagic vacuoles and rounded
mitochondria with dramatically disorder
and amorphous structure so clec 16a
controls mitophagy and maintains
mitochondrial function thank you for
watching science breakthroughs from sign